je demande c'est squeeze et aujourd'hui
on se retrouve avec mister big boy 45
pour une vidéo sur battlefield 3 pc donc
je risque un tout petit peu de lag et
donc désolé si le gameplay même pas
fameux oui c'est une suis dit voilà il
dit tout ça parce que t'es pas chez vous
regarde la carte regard de la taille de
la carte
ça promet quelque chose de gigantesque
mais c'est immense
c'est surtout magnifiquement watros home
allégeance utile et les graphismes pc
parce qu'ils sont prêts
et donc c'est vrai légaux et même si la
première partie sur armand et il en fait
j'ai je n'ai acheté hier soir j'étais
chargé mon sens s'en fout c'est ma vie
pas créer 4 gigas les quatre cartes fois
c'est un giga la carte quasi ouais mais
sauf que moi je veut se taper klaus
quarters avec et j'ai pas kiffer ouais
ouais bon voilà enfin c'était deux
heures année au total que j'avais de
quoi un peu pourri mais bon on a fait
une partie du terrain c'est ma deuxième
partie sur le jeu zombie boy
alors non mais le mur s'est cassé mais
genre le bois derrière nantes inquiète
ça c'est ce qu'on dit non mais c'est ma
deuxième chantier donc sûr je disais
alors que bebo ils vont soit on a fait
un petit peu plus d'an visage en effet
j'ai fait quelques heures quand même
vrai nom c'est moi c'est vrai je connais
l ai fait quelques dégâts aux gardes
allemands cdo là j'ai l'impression que
c'est mieux optimisé je sais pas
pourquoi mais son avatar
tu es mort de paiement rouches n'ont
même pas le temps qu'ils descendent
quand je dis décembre d'esquiver passer
à côté d'un tank
bah si mais je sais pas moi d'habitude
je continue en mode easy non parce que
là en fait si tu veux je voulais aller
au drapeau ben écoute on va apparaître
sur la montagne un montagneux à cheval
non on va paraître sur ces tient comme
ça on va prendre b et quoi comme classe
pas là je suis en vie actuellement tiens
j'ai c'est très bien ça tu veux soir
j'ai mis quelques temps c'est mieux
optimisé chez passé qu'une impression
mais là j'ai frappe c'est c'est pourtant
je fais quarante cinq images 2d ou
langages utilisés en europe ce jeu c'est
pas que j'ai raison que ces vides les
couleurs sont mieux non mais le jeu le
pack est superbe autre façon tout court
c'est vraiment franchement il en met
plein la gueule baptisée koala dit toi
tu as vu honnêtement la vue un quart de
l'amap de ce que tu vois là à l'horizon
mais je sais pas mais là c'est vraiment
beaucoup plus beau que taken je suis là
je suis en berne on va sur b j'ai
vraiment l'heure sauf que c'est beaucoup
plus beau job première impression que tu
es sur les mac de base du bf donc bon
c'est plutôt qu'un puits même niveau il
ya un tank attention attends je vais
essayer de mettre une roquette mazet
l'osi je m'occupe de prendre derrière
attend voir si ça marche tu dans la jeep
je t'attends bad et si jamais y est go
je veux tu t'inquiètes à ces gars là on
va carrément allé dans le désert
d'accord si ça te gêne pas trop naze y
aller chercher la grosse nouveauté donc
de du mapaq c'est le à monique papa nick
papas nie pas ces gens du deux roues les
filles rocket c'était comme regarder le
temps qu'il est à l'autre bout du truc
quoi avant-hier canonnière tiendra le 8
mai 3 alors jeté pour avoir la
canonnière apparaît sur le tient à paris
sur eux moi ça fait un petit contrat la
voilà donc passé justement j'en parlais
gisait la grosse nouveauté du mapaq en
dehors des couleurs qui ont l'air bien
meilleure et de l'optimisation qui est
mieux et assez plat c 130
je suis sur eux bien tant qu'un rien
tant que jouer effectivement je le
regarde et beau essayer tout le temps
occupé je vais apparaître sur ton occupé
à deux attentats lors par newcastle et
squeeze oui mais là je meure jamais je
suis jamais céder et classe c 130
la grosse nouveauté du paquet ce qui
attire un petit peu tous les joueurs à
passer
je m'en suis occupé
voilà parfait c'est vraiment l'a630 donc
je n'ai jamais joué de danger vous du
trio d'un game et un camion lui
l'idée d'un gameplay c'était fou
attention à trier et on va chercher pour
toi attends je vais me jeter dessus
balas et son tronc que tu peux le voir
dans la magnifique
tiens tu es prêt alors la vue j'étais un
bon gars la direction c'est super rapide
sans voix de la patate je te propose
qu'on a exercé pendant que tu raconte la
vie de la c 130 voilà donc je disais que
j'ai regardé la vidéo de la 130 donc
premièrement le gard à faire un câlin
monsters qu'il assez impressionnant faut
bien le dire ou le saut est-ce que c'est
facile ou pas tu sois vivant et de faire
par contre il a un défaut l'a630 c'est
qu'il est trop facile à détruire c'est
deux avions dans la gueule de roquettes
on entend le plus quoi ah ouais ouais
c'est ça qu'il était aussi fragile qu'un
avion donc c'est un peu dommage c'est
quand même balès comme avion va pas se
mentir c'est un droit mais n'importe qui
peut la voir la session trentesaux c'est
énorme ce qu'ils ont fait en fait si tu
veux il ya un point sur la map
bien joué j'ai plus de trucs péri il ya
un mois
maintenant on va se aussi bien des il ya
un point sur la mappe si tu préfères
août à une petite icône double ils
appellent ça la canonnière mais c'est la
c 130
la petite icône de la c 130 et si on à
ce point on a là c 130
adacore qui est le seul moyen d'avoir
mon cas car il bosse il me semble
exactement il me semble que c'est le
point g donc si on a le point g on a là
c'est 130
je comprends d'accord affronte pour la
voir il faut qu'on tue la c 130 et demi
en attendant tout le nôtre apparaissent
il pas bayonnais vente en même temps
quoi ouais tiens à temps je peux te
sauveras banon suis pas médecin allez
salut salut
d'accord je vois ok alors attends à
[ __ ] il y avait un avion j'en ai marre
dès qu'un véhicule je n'arrive pas à
voir
moi je vais attendre dix secondes soit
une apparition je suis un truc et puis
on va se balader dans le désert soit tu
fais tu as wihr bon ratures jarek marge
des spots sur toi c'est un peu plus
grand quand même je veux mais on me dit
qu'ils portent porterait à comme ça
ouais mais attend
le but du mythique faut pas que ça soit
cm à 1 m inquiète pas au pire je meurs
tu prends au bac et buts en coupes des
films dans les dents étaient up regarde
ça c'est là qu'on dit non mais comme
cela mais c'est normal joli coup tu peux
la voir là vas-y vas-y vas-y poursuit
drôle tu vois le gars n'a pas là on les
craint retrace tanger du lay avait
écrasé le cras de grâce de nom il a eu
bien joué alors la torah roquettes
auraient une roquette tu te serais mis à
côté de moi si tu aurais eu un hélico
avec une roquette à bombay reconduit
[ __ ] le little bear ben oui nous tombe
dessus écoute prend une roquette on s'en
fout on va l'arraché avec un peu d'eau
je crois qu est un avion on parie
combien cette balade en avion
super rageant c'est qu'on doit des
comptes en banque un [ __ ] de véhicules
telle est sur la touche enter et non le
fait voler par condé 2 essaye d'avoir
que l'hélico en l'air la adoma à jordi
mach le viper genre au méchant qui suit
à témoin mais non mais georges je n'ai
pas eu à temps un accroc ciel [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] là le n o mais voila voila
je suis majoritaire a nommé stigma
[ __ ] je suis fâché non messieurs le
viper face à moi c'était un précieux aux
allemands
c'était juste impressionnant il ya juste
un temps que face à moi malheureusement
je n'ai pas de moyens - attends moi j'ai
un pouvoir envoyer moment
ouais non mais c'est énorme et dit toi
tu peux avoir la canonnière avec ton rpg
dit 'tiens tu le vois la ola ouais mais
tu peux l'avoir ouais mais c'est super
chaud puisque en plus ils à la hauteur
et wafa ouais ouais non mais ça c'est
c'est un truc de malade mais tu sais que
c'est pour toi que je laisse à mon team
des vidéos avec toi y'a pas de soucis
sauf des cadeaux en vidéo à dieu allait
bien des roquettes attends je me suicide
et j'ai 40 ans je manque de rythme était
sérieux ouais c'est ça c'est bon on
était au milieu de rien par contre si
non mettait en débat au milieu de rien
n'était sur l'a1 tornato on parie
combien y'a rien il est oublié oublier
bon sens ne trie pas de jeu l'es1
tu l'as bien joué j'arrive à temps je
peux péter la c 130
avec quoi ton affirme ann webb a bien
sûr attendre si je vais péter on va voir
alors au plan de sauvetage fait deux
tours si c'est dégueulasse alors par
contre à gmail faut quand même étonné
faut pas jouer à ça enfin tu peux pas
jouer ajourne disant je vais faire du 50
pour un an tu vois c'est pas possible
sur des cartes aussi grande et tout vu
je fais pas une partie très que je vois
tu t'en tu passes en 50 ml gens ils
peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent tu peux
pas croisés à chaque fois 150 minutes
personnel mais ça c'est sûr écoute je me
ferais bien une petite balade aussi
autres of the sky
le 30 mai le cross to be or not to be
j'ai pris la hougue là mon gars je suis
chaud comme la braise
je vais aller sur lacanau au loyer de
l'hélico là en veux tu en voilà tempère
je vais essayer de te cover expo tête et
celico appuyez sur a fait dans un avis
que toi j'en vois alors moi je suis dans
l'avion mais je suis dans un hélico un
[ __ ] je veux me paraît voilà à chaque
fois pied sur ses annoncé que savent pas
pour passer en vie à trois personnes sur
les quais ne savent pas ce qui
m'étonnerait quand même oui oui oui moi
c'est toujours sympa pour passer on va
dire et là je me fais luck x non moins
charmant petit quad je crois que je te
vois un débat mais en fait ouais je me
fais pour suivre mon avis
non pas ton avis c'est quasi sûr si tu
reçois des trucs dans la gueule c'est
que c'est sûr mais fais gaffe qui est du
jab l'un est tous et oublie pas là on
est que 48 donc c'est ça va on est bien
64 voilà on n'est pas 64 mais déjà là on
croit se passe c'est vraiment énorme
les cartes sont énormes a hâte en cédant
choper un puits ce qui s'est passé mais
c'est leur [ __ ] là elle avait la
canonnière volante oh [ __ ] attend les
fruits d'un an voilà
et oui faut courir premier arrivé
premier servi et d'apparaître sur b
peut-être non b et voient leurs ouailles
à de la gare sont des oies et moi je
fais ça je suis là à l'ego tiens on
prendra pas en même temps par contre tu
feras car il ya du monde sur ben je sais
pas où ils sont ces petits salopiots
jawhar jean marchand compte tarifs mais
grave quoi mais cette arme de lancer une
catastrophe a tenté sur belle six mois
j'étais sur ces attentions qui rentrent
dans le bâtiment en incarnant le
bâtiment j'arrive pas à prendre le truc
à cause d'un [ __ ] de temps car à cons
yuuwaa faire attention fait attention il
ya le temps attends je vais mourir bien
galaga non c'est un temps que ça
s'appelle non non il ya un gagnant
gagnant sur la droite il m'a tuer m'a
tuer les dirigeants
laissez moi me soigner quoi sérieux
assez énervant et c'est vrai qu'en bon
j'investis super score sur le noble
comme ça surtout quand on est en vidéo à
la ba voila je suis mort pour toi si tu
pouvais ramasse mais bon un peu non mais
je l'aimé à combien de % de villa wafou
ressent 3% - battu l'az non mais c'est
déjà ça franchement c'est rageant bon on
reprend un chinois tan parachutage
caraquet non non non on regarde où il
est sur la marque tu vas le parachuté
dans lola bon on remarque tu peux tu
veux du décor ça pognait lazare
manson ou quand je vais sur l on ma part
je laisserais fonds à prendre un quad
est ce que tu es toujours un g ouais
toujours on va tenter des trucs de
hockey tu sais sur l'avion va prendre un
quad tu va tenter de démolir en plein
quad quelque chose avec ton par rocket
adac en outre je suis moi [ __ ] je suis
mort fait guère gesppe l'hôtel caron
phase 1 ouais je sais j'ai loupé la dyle
arrive il arrive je sais je le vois à
tendance est maintenant bossnapping
brooking attend à l'égard de nathan est
ce que tu veux que je vienne me chercher
peut-être à temps et là on les lit
bougeait attend c'est super chaud pour
moi je viendrai en élite mais non mais
mais cette arme mais attendez quoi aussi
des balles non mais c'est dacquois
lancent des cailloux
ouais c'est ça et lancent des cailloux
des cailloux d'un lance-roquette la thur
offrir de la vue la tat abonnés carrière
volante cholet alors mettez dont je te
vois parfois exploser à dieppe l'été je
suis recherché squeeze aux [ __ ]
journée mikko attend donc un temps qui
un tank est la télé sur un tank est né
t'es où t'es sérieux ou 6 6 4
ah bah non s'il ne tue pas j'ai beaucoup
de chance je suis d une voiture
actuellement c'est une voiture modèle à
ses anciens plutôt moche tu es tu sais
que tu peux conduire des sortes de
camions bennes mais ouais j'ai vu j'ai
fait ça juste avant c'était épique
j'arrive crise il ya un tas en k1 prends
ton âge je me suffis code alors mais tu
fais chier non mais c'est naples je me
retourne au mois de mai au tour je me
fais que toi non mais parfois je
comprends pas quoi non mais ça les jours
vient dé taillé un avion je peux pas me
paraît juste et surtout être un peu plus
drôle aux [ __ ] rien mais qui se la
pète en quad la mort attend j'arrive tu
es sûre d ouais je suis arrivé rouillé
jaquette et la boîte à keith jarrett
j'arrive je suis vite fait monter dans
l'avion
tu es à 1000 mètres 900 jetons 107 106
105 100 adieu non non non non non non
non non si si j'ai pas le choix
non mais attends je suis pas mort mais
je me suis parachuté quoi je suis perdue
au milieu du décès de sa fille ou d'un
parachute à bagages et les radios
disaient mais c'est violent tu peux
venir me chercher
ouais mais je sais pas où tu es dans le
désert la boîte est mort bah ouais je
suis mort battant mettait encore damas
battant n'était plus dans ma tante est
plus dans mon lit web à temps mais j'ai
pas tweet shimla ils m'ont pas switching
automatiquement attend à [ __ ] ils
t'ont switch team ouais bon mais
écoutons ce fait la guerre c'est pas
grave c'est bon c'est vrai j'ai changé
j'ai changé mon ballet bien des données
squat il reste une place pour toi alors
ça c'est le gros défaut c'est que sur pc
il te souhaite jeter mais tout en quoi
c'est franchement c'était franchement ça
c'est énervant surtout quand on abat
cancan là tu vois tu joueras été tes
potes mais c'est j'avoue que ça c'est
plutôt énervant mais encore avant on
galérait encore plus on joue ensemble
sur pc ouais ouais je sois mon
affirmation quoi j'étais dans un avion
de chasse soit tu te la joues top gun 2
puis de taninges et après tu viens ils
ont quand même rouler bien faire ton
show attentats pas essayez là oh ouais
attends je vais revenir illico derrière
moi j'ai ramené à quatre mois
ouais bah moi je vais repartir surtout
soldats à tailler un hélico attends je
vais chercher en hélico jeunes
chercheurs ont bien qu'à venir violente
violente
j'aurais viol à les serveuses un peu ça
effectivement bien donner des coups
viendront hélico bibette mais j'peux pas
pu ou attentes et où je passe te
chercher et on a une coupe
ouais ouais confiance messi mais
franchement les choses bien j'arrive
bien résilient arrive en jeep en plus
bas
du désert c'est moi ou acheter watch
paris dakar vous présente au [ __ ] je
vais faire le saut la mort vas-y bien je
rentre en plein vol était de me choper h
trop lointain allez je te répartir et
par là où bat nantes à keith hackett
attend il ya un temps que là bas si j
leroy requête
je tire alors ok tu essayes de tourner
un petit peu histoire que je puisse la
voir à la roquette si jamais tel quel
côté je suis le côté droite ok il est où
là il ouvre par le salut nazi vélo
attend si proche de lui un petit peu
vas-y vas-y vas-y je te dis contourner
fais gaffe on sait on essuie des tirs
maman malade
y avait il est là il est là il a je le
marque à temps il est exactement sur tu
peux aller sur eux c'est parfait mange
marocaine au lololol alors vas-y vas-y
tu en veux tu tires lui ont valu mettre
la misère frôle pas droit je suis pris
quoi j'ai compris la parabole des
regards craignos du jouet tu pilotes
avec quoi sinon en dehors de ça rien à
voir avec les pièces non une manette ou
un clavier non [ __ ] je me suis
parachuté au milieu du désert en fait
faut utiliser les les cloches des
cloches logis l'itw will et de l'est
pourquoi pourquoi te disent les cloches
c'était assez chaud segré c'est la
fatigue le qui dominait 6 et les attends
je vais essayer de choper j'hallucine
encore de ce que j'ai fait alors
franchement halal oui bah tu utilises
toile et wet utilisent les cloches mais
je te conseille d'utiliser une manette
une manette xbox filaire sites à leur
nom avec les toucher un peu plus simple
je trouve
ah non non mais juste pour conduire je
parle pas pour jouer dès qu'on a conduit
un hélico tu prends la manette wii
zenawi la mm même jeu
puis j'ai plus de facilités aux claviers
même si on ne dirait pas de monter avec
toi l'un vient avaient attaqué attaqué
cette fois on va aller mais tu sais que
quelqu'un avec toi tes côtés un ah oui
merde oh mais c'est comment tu atterris
doigts vas-y vas-y fais-le sortir l'a
fait n'importe quoi il ya un an et demi
là où il vat arraché mon gars la
tacatacatique parfois vas-y je te
couvrir je répare le truc alors [ __ ]
c'est chaud des news mais là je suis
entré dedans moment we cheer badia it
here avec ce truc à la con là bas c'est
relou ça va aller on va en en asie on va
en centre-ville et ont fait la guerre
quand un bijou de change de trottoir
vas-y t'inquiète qui attaque est devancé
à tanger sortir une nouvelle arme parce
que là j'en ai marre les crocs djihad
mais je ne trouvais plus puissants
avants je sais pas ce qu'ils ont si l'on
fait quelque chose haute mais là je
trouve vraiment dégueu ap ap on peut
gratter des points là j'arrive explosé
mais grave
jean nous procédons j'ai survécu ah
ouais j'ai mûri j'ai prouvé alors la
roquette c'est un mini sommet au plus
tard nicolas pour nous et en quoi je
suis en âge est vrai nom mais ça
m'aurait fait très chaud régulière au
plus tard mais pour nous le bird rigueur
fais gaffe c'est du tonkin
il ya du temps on va se le faire mais au
nom mais mec mais c'est ouf quand et pas
dans un [ __ ] mais je suis en train de
mai 2,2 me faire oui très rassurant
armor kills et de la poutre info jouer
des heures et des heures franchement
pour s'habituer
pour moi c'est comme si tu étais sûr sur
un jeu différent mais enfin c'est
bizarre
toi tu vas c'est l'habitude mais c'est
vraiment grand c'est une autre façon de
jouer quoi que les maps voilà c'est
exactement ça c'est notre façon de jouer
en gros pour ceux qui tiennent vraiment
à leur ratio c'est pas sûr à mon équipe
qui vont trouver leur bonheur oui ah non
ça c'est qu'ils jouent pour le ratio
c'est clair vous faites opération métro
relie vous allez vous le booster des
conseils ou alors que l'osce quarters
certains parce que moi aussi je voyage
adore les couleurs de la map
qu attend ça change vraiment ah non
c'est vrai j'ai regardé enfin il est
illogique en français honnêtement les
couleurs ont tendance à être plutôt
sombre et pas trop de finges patron n'y
a pas trop de contrastes
alors tu te tapes a vu la plus belle ma
pour moi où l'attend prend plein la
gueule mais gens violents mais quand je
te dis violence et violente
c'est dans les montagnes ouais et si tu
fais là je te sens fébrile avec des
touches donc quand on réaménage ta
maison du tout c'est que j'avais peur à
temps j'arrive à temps voilà c'était
quoi c'était voilà c'est dans les
montagnes c'est vraiment sublime alors
là c'est dès que tu vois ça tu dis faut
que je fasse une vidéo dessus parce que
c'est énorme énorme
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas encore vu les
mythos pour m le quad qui arrivait au
[ __ ] tu fous rien rien rien rien rien
on va le réparer par fait pas c'est pas
moi c'est pas moi on se fait plus
déglinguée moi je dirais c'est le
problème de la map regarde oui les ongs
rixson small mais qui bouge pas c'est le
problème de la map c'est que en fait tu
te prends desmo tu te prends déjà blain
c'est au temps prend plein la gueule
coup franchement c'est le jeu c'est le
panneau mais si ça super lourd le mec
qui campent au delà gré mais mec je sors
le stade je le poutre à monga n'y a rien
à benghazi basit
elle est là ou là qu'elle essaye de le
noter si tu peux et bien mes toiles ah
ouais quand même
vas-y je prends le snipe aussi lente
alors à temps parce que moi je suis à la
coque
cet égard je t'aime pas le ricain je te
préviens moi lâchait pas content il ya
trop de temps qui attend que ça abusé
quoi écoute tu veux vraiment qu'on est
ce ce n'est as mais j'en ai marre
nous on est mort ah ben ouais les mecs
mais par avec un camion qua non un mec
dont une espèce de tourelles de merde
ouais attend de ces coiffes sur la fois
12 alors là puisque j'ai lu déjoué halak
holmes net le mail à d'aussi loin que
c'est un petit peu dur quand même mais
attends juste pas de surcroît williams
et qu'on peut se le faire long feu heath
to fail ouais non mais mec moi je sens
je l'aurais leur a dit aux gars tu là
non tu peux la baie opta j'aime être
marque hogan du don non mes mecs mais ça
me rend ouf
mais ça mourant mettez tout le temps en
train de mourir coiffe est il vraiment
les mecs qui sont ce [ __ ] à 630
annoncé que je vais citer en infanterie
été désavantagé dans ce mode là là bon
on s'en fout on des liens ok n'importe
quoi mais là mais c'est chaud sinon
c'est que du véhicule et c'est tout le
temps comme ça on t'attend même pas
avoir la mémoire moi je vais passer en
mode sniper campeurs la jalle mais yahia
neutralité sur la grue j'espionné sur
lui je passe ambassadeur campeurs c'est
parti alors où êtes-vous et s'est
installé sur fc lagarde craignos moi je
suis pas mort je suis vraiment encore
wawe match prend des balles groupe mais
non mais non truffe ah ouais ça fait une
belle qu un adam mais si pire qu'un film
de cul non mais attends mais un [ __ ]
mais c'est tant que là bas la tam et
emma ne t'es mal
ils tirent des obus sur la grille s'te
plaît je prends tarif est grave mais
c'est ça ou à mes mecs aiment et or ne
travailles pas tu es l et je vais dire à
mes j'en peux plus
arbitres assistants qui se font soit en
gros un médecin ne sert quasiment à rien
sur cette manne mais ces violences et
violon en plus là bas on est dans
l'équipe des perdants c'est un peu
craignos messi ou fayat échec dans la
team quelqu'un de ma team regarde en
l'air le feu d'artifice dommage atteint
bassij et spawn sur trois et on prend le
temps qu'on les tienne à messaâd anc de
merde
non non non non on croit pas c'est un
ghetto inquiète pas
bon c'est vrai que je suis pas passé par
le meilleur chemin à temps bouge pas
patrick regnault moi je met franchement
les gens sont super important de spoil
les ennemis jahia pas comme ça à bidart
ça aide bien
non mais en plus il faut préciser que
c'est la première fois non sur se passe
pour toi au chaud s'il tombe de cette
manière c'est parti huawei tombé en
piqué s'est faite à couture voire sauver
la grèce et cru dans un mag et dansaient
et ne s'échappent et de la comète
il ne peut pas en fait la nasse cavale
fait c'est que ça vibre vraiment trop
fort mais elle fait bien fait justement
c'est que ça faisait tellement que je
peux je pourrais pas te tue à l'arrière
ne me cache peut pas tuer quoi tellement
ça vibre comment ça tellement ce film
belge pas ça vibre genre le point il
vivra dans le tank
de son côté alain je suis de face devant
c'est bon j'ai acheté fumigènes à temps
bon ben on y va en plus de celles ci ont
ajouté ces objectifs te pas que c'est
une longue balade en fait tu vois moi ça
fait ça mais c'est aux autres mais
franchement c boelle effectivement bon
allez on prend ce merdier mois basée à
l'est on essaie de prendre un point mais
tâchez sortie annuelle qui m'ont frôlait
j'ai pas compris
oh [ __ ] ou la bouche de la bouche de
là il est derrière son dubaï derrière ça
mais c'est un temps que c'est un tank
oh [ __ ] on se bat face à wigan l'avion
on essaye de le démonter attendant il
est super loin en fait non bah je sais
pas c'est lui là bas battant je le
répare je vais pas attendre pape arrive
à les démonter
vas-y voyage évolué ici bonjour j
attends monte à bavois là bas et ce qui
est bien sûr pas comment lama a
franchement même bien au niveau au
niveau pire qu'un film de cul ce que tu
te prends ma 2,16 là quelqu'un qui
jouait pour le ratio je crois qu'ils
auraient effectivement pleurer mais
regarde les scores de tout le monde
c'est partout pareil atteint 3 18
ça fait malgré les choix qu'il a faits
du 08 non magie rage que je voulais pas
dans mon score plus long terme en tout
cas j'espère cette petite découverte
d'amour et il en compagnie de me
survivre car vous aura plu
j attends rien que ça sent bon la vidéo
gère la roquette à ces la roquette de
bboy qui était absolument magnifique du
jeu libyen film et on l'a bien vu partir
alors là l'équipe à part je n'y sois sur
la chaîne secondaire du vase et que si
tu veux accor axa l'on appelle bon en
tout cas on se retrouve dans une
nouvelle vidéo et pourquoi pas vos
vidéos plus tard bboy si vous voulez
laisser leurs commentaires
et puis à bientôt pis talent et tout le
monde